what are your first impressions been a
mac this week as you've joined him on
the practice field
uh matt good energy uh awesome guy man
uh
you can tell he's happy to be here um
comes to work
and uh you know you just could feel his
energy and his leadership
uh already uh he has a swag to him that
i didn't know that he had at first you
know he's out there
he's out there confident and that's what
you need in a quarterback
and then all our players you know you
gotta have confidence so uh he's coming
in with that
and i feel like that's going to take
them a long way
new patriots receiver kendrick bourne
talking about new patriots quarterback
mack jones 15th overall pick in the
draft the guy that some still are
convinced was initially going to be the
third overall pick in the draft the
49ers until they pivoted
to trey lance you know mike reese of
espn.com had an item over the weekend he
had been to the ota practice on thursday
and he said mac jones running that
offense
seemingly throwing the ball where it was
supposed to go
every time yes it's off season yes it's
against
you know guys who aren't trying to come
decapitate you
but he was making good decisions in an
offense where you have to show a mastery
of that attack and so far so good
for mack jones in competition with cam
newton chris but
number 30 without ever taking a snap in
the nfl that's right the chris sims
top 40 quarterback countdown ahead of a
super bowl
yeah participant right and jared goff is
mac jones at number
yeah you know more talented i'm sorry
you know and yeah he's a rookie but he's
an experienced rookie and i know it was
only 17 games in college but it's all
those years at alabama
all right and playing the tough sec
schedule and everything about that
and all the things you hear right now
listen it's been nothing but positives
all you you don't even hear things about
these the like first round picks in new
england they're they're
they're quietly gushing about him that
just tells you it all
he is the most nfl ready quarterback to
come out in the draft this year
hands down that's why he was valued so
high
he can play in any offense other than
lamar jackson
he's a high level thrower of the
football as accurate as you're gonna get
in the nfl already right now you know
anticipation
feel in the pocket it's all top notch
that's where mac jones is really special
and you know to add to what kendrick
bourne said
one of the biggest things i heard this
is where it's funny with mac jones
because i mean we talked about it a lot
right
wish he would wear his uniform better or
look a little different wish he would
look a little cooler
he's like aka nerdy white guy with a dad
bod yet he's 24 or 23 years old
but anybody you talk to alabama new
england so far whatever
mac jones has a real edge and swagger
about him that is real
and i think you know you could tell by
listening to his receivers last year
devonte smith and jalen waddle
that there's a real leadership factor
about what he brings to the table too
but yes i think he's ready to go right
now nfl ready
and yeah i give him the advantage over a
guy like jared goff you heard me say
last week
i mean jared goff i'm not all that
impressed with his physical abilities
and he doesn't play the game like an
experienced fifth or sixth year type
quarterback
so that's where it's like okay there's
no advantage to be had there
mac jones uh i i really i'm excited
about i don't know if he plays this year
but when he does
i think it's going to be damn good i
just wonder whether bill belichick takes
mack jones into the equipment manager's
office and says make this guy
look less like bobby lane seriously
it was just it was it really was an
obvious quality the way his body looked
the way his uniform fit it just was like
this guy's a
quarterback who's highly regarded by the
nfl something doesn't compute here
i know we have seen over time even
though it's not like
quarterbacks for the most part are cut
up and but they're they're not
dumpy looking and right he's kind of
dumpy looking he's square looking
yeah it's it's it's ultimately not going
to matter if you can get the football
where it needs to be here's bill
belichick from last week we played this
on friday chris i want you to hear this
talking about both cam newton and mac
jones because i think belichick
likes both of them which is going to
make the decision as to who starts even
harder
cam has been here um you know all the
way through um
he was here you know at the beginning
and you know has been
been a consistent participant you know
continues to give us the usual
um you know leadership and and um
you know energy that he brings to the
field into the workouts and
and to practice so um
you know cam's cam's very professional
and i i'm sure that he'll you know
continue to work hard to do his best out
there like he's always done for us it's
never been anything but that
uh from the day he got here but really
we're starting everybody at the same
point like we always do
uh this time of year so you know max
mac dove into the playbook and continues
to do that and
um you know like everybody out there you
know
we all have a lot of things we got to
work on and that that includes everybody
and
and so that's what he's doing that's
what everybody's doing
when you were in your hammock peter and
i discussed on friday the reality that
even though there's some nepotism in the
coaching staff with a couple of
belichicks not named bill
who work under him it's a meritocracy on
the field he's going to go with the guy
who
gives the team the best chance to win
and
it's going to be a hell of a decision
because you can make the argument that
either guy
can help the patriots win this year no i
i mean i i
you know i think mac jones like i said
he's he's nfl ready
there's no doubt about it that's the
kind of football he played at alabama
and you know if there is a rookie that
could come in there and start it would
be
this guy you know i've heard the phrase
blown away
by what they've seen to this point come
out of new england
blown away so that's doesn't mean it's
just like
average or okay or he's working hard
that that means there's a little
something more to it
now i don't expect them to be the
starter i still expect it to be cam
newton
but i do think that like mac jones will
challenge
and new england's gonna like what they
see from the guy
you know the big thing too going back to
what you said before we got to the
belichick press
conference there you know the looks
hey the looks you got to get past the
looks yeah i know they don't look good
but the results and what you watch on
the field are outstanding
constantly mike constantly i mean his
feet his movement in the pocket was as
good as anybody in the draft it was the
best
accuracy probably the best in the draft
decision making the speed in which you
could go through
and like read and react and diagnose
coverages and all that
like i told you it was the best in the
draft as good as i've ever seen
other than joe burrow from two years ago
so all those things
are you know pretty special and of
course
really held in high regard in new
england and that's where to me people
are missing on the mac jones and mike
mike people are already they're already
covering their tracks with mac jones all
the haters in the world that oh i can't
believe he's going to be drafted in
front of jason
justin fields and trey lance and all
that type of stuff
all the people you know there was the
excuse well you know if
the 49ers take him well then he's got
shenahan's offense so it'll work
and oh no new england took them so it'll
work because it's new england's offense
but i don't hear that with trey lance
now i thought it should work he should
be able to play
let's go that's where i don't like these
double messages sent out about certain
players
but he's a damn good player and he's in
the top 30 for me as you see as far as
quarterbacks
and for the first time ever there will
be a three-game preseason this year for
all teams except for the cowboys and
steelers
and for the patriots there's a
three-game regular season
pre-season that precedes the week four
showdown against hashtag
tommy that's
i don't care what bill belichick says we
take it a game at a time we're on to
cincinnati
you want whether it's mac jones or cam
newton yeah you want that guy to be
ready
for week four sunday night the guy that
gives them the best chance to beat tom
brady oh by the way cam newton
two-and-oh all-time against tom brady
even though quarterback wins aren't a
stat it's worth pointing it out all
right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports